here at CBS we are committed to stopping
the stigma surrounding mental health so
we can take the shame and the blame out
of discussing mental illnesses we feel
strongly about this this morning we're
introducing you to some young people
trying to do exactly that one in six
children and teenagers ages 6 to 17
experience of mental health disorder
every year in the United States suicide
is the second leading cause of death for
people between the ages of 10 to 34 our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
recently went to Minnesota to see our
young people are they're taking the lead
to improve their own mental health
Jericka good morning to you what did you
learn here well I learned that these
young people simply want to be heard the
goal of the event is to stop the stigma
in this case young people are doing that
by speaking up a couple of weeks ago at
youth cultural healing summit
Minnesotans took center stage to
transform their pain into perseverance
hundreds of people gathered at this
church in downtown Minneapolis for
lessons on healing and resiliency Marny
- Radel runs the nonprofit that
co-hosted the summit with the catalyst
initiative it really was a brainchild of
a group of young people who came to us
and said there's so much happening in
our communities whether it's violence
whether it's poverty whether it's
feeling dislocated can you help us build
a space where we can come together and
heal healing starts with what I would
say 25 year old Mariana Morgan Sawyer
says acknowledgement played a big role
in her own healing she's a part of a
nonprofit that started with a group of
public school kids at risk of dropping
out
why do you think it's imposing for
people especially young people of color
to have a place like this I think it's
important to receive the information so
one that there's such a thing as trauma
two that there's something that you can
do about it you don't have to just walk
around being sad or angry all the time
there are ways that we can unpack these
things for ourselves they unpack their
own trauma through theater and by
sharing concrete tools this is a thing
that you can do or use when you're
feeling stressed so that has definitely
helped me in my journey but also that
there's hope we don't have to be stuck
in these emotions we can deal with them
and it's much more fulfilling when it
happens in community eight-year-old to
know when they're suffering from
depression but the adults aren't always
ready to have that conversation for
bonus points ask somebody to skip with
you and hold hands Marnie - Riedel wants
kids to be the architects of their own
future not the victims of someone else's
my body was evidence of a felony in 17
states until it was six years old you
introduced yourself today and said when
I was born my body was evidence of a
crime in 1962 and until 1967 with Loving
v Virginia
there were anti-miscegenation laws so
White's could not marry blacks and I am
clearly a woman of color and so when I
was born I'm listed as white on my birth
certificate and then when I was seven
months old my melanin came in and so my
biological grandmother gave my
biological mother the choice of either
giving me up for adoption or banishing
her from the family she made the choice
to put me into the foster care system
shrade oh never had a safe space so she
was compelled to create one for others
we have to stand in solidarity with
these young people and understand that
their lives are complicated they're
having drills at school about shooters
so to see young people in this room
today have so much potential and all
they're asking for is support authentic
connection these Native American actors
performed a play based on their
experiences it was so personal they
asked us to only film the beginning but
their stories connected with teenager
kiante Dunbar not seen in the name of
America of play that connected with me a
lot because like my parents defy a lot
does it help to be around people that
have experienced that similar type of
trauma to know that you're not alone
yeah because you can like talk to them
and they actually understand how
[Music]
important is it for you and people who
look like you to be able to open up I
think it's a big thing a big deal
because a lot of african-american males
think it's not okay to have mental
health issues or like that's a white
people thing what are you walking away
from here today with that you didn't
have when you came through the door
probably more confidence to like open up
and talk to people the event organizers
tell us they get about fifty to sixty
calls a week from people across the
country asking how they can put together
similar youth cultural healing summits
there is clearly a willingness to bring
people together and focus on wellness so
it went very well they were satisfied
with the the turnout it happened on a
day where public schools were out so
they had a really great turnout from
people all across that area it shows
once again how important it is to show
that you were not alone whatever it is
you're going through somebody else is
going to it to seems your voice held up
look like what a great story very
important thank you thank you thank you
very much